now to this other story that we've been
following here at CBS this morning
people living near some air bases are
expressing concerns after the EPA
detected toxic chemicals that may have
seeped into local drinking water
chemicals known as PFCs
are in things like some nonstick pans
stain free carpets and cleaning supplies
well they have also been a main
component of firefighting foam used at
military bases and airports and they are
associated with health problems like
cancer and low birth weight Mary
Peterson is at Peterson Air Force Base
in Colorado Springs with the residents
concerns very good morning good morning
Nora well here at Peterson Air Force
Base they know the contamination from
this foam has seeped into the water
supply and they're working with the
communities to clean that water up but
for people who have lived here for years
who have been drinking that water for
years there's real fear that there's
something dangerous in their bodies do
you ever think like there's danger right
down here like down right there well the
water is under the ground
it it's always in the back of my mind of
what's what's lurking down there before
25 years
dan Cruz delivered mail here and drank
the water then came cancer thyroid
prostate testicular he says never before
seen and his family are the only one
that's been diagnosed with cancer not
once not twice but three times people on
my route cancer has come upon them and
sometimes a stage for the cause could be
firefighting foam used since the 1970s
at Air Force bases and airports across
the country something meant to save
lives that may have harmed them instead
the phone contains highly fluorinated
chemicals known as pfcs
it is suspected of causing some cancers
in underweight births
I like how quiet it is Micah Pullum has
lived near Peterson Air Force Base for a
quarter century in a town where the foam
has contaminated the water she almost
died several times said he was born
premature weighing a mere 1 pound 6
ounces
she spent 94 days in the neonatal
intensive care unit that's the first
time I got to hold her city is one of
three children born to Micah four other
pregnancies ended in miscarriage
with what you know now do you think any
of this has to do with the effects
potential effects of what's in the water
possibly yeah what because if you
continue to pump poison into your body
something has to respond Peterson is one
of a hundred ninety Air Force bases
where PFC s may have leached into the
ground and surrounding areas one study
based on EPA's test results show as many
as six million people may be exposed
nationwide to PFC s in their drinking
water at higher levels than the EPA now
deemed safe but more than sixty thousand
people in the communities near Peterson
Air Force Base may be America's hardest
hit the EPA says anything over 70 parts
per trillion could be dangerous some
water they tested here had over 1300
parts per trillion and according to a
proposed class-action lawsuit filed
against the foam manufacturers it has
caused serious medical conditions in
hundreds of residents one foam
manufacturing company 3m says there is
no merit in the health claims adding
they sold these products with
instructions regarding their safe use
and disposal acted responsibly at all
times and will vigorously defend this
lawsuit but the Air Force has taken
action spending more than four million
dollars to provide bottled water and
filtration systems
Air Force firefighters now trained with
water and for real fires it uses a
different fluorinated foam still
containing another type of PFCs but
believed to be safer but some of those
who have studied the new phone say the
airforce may have traded one evil for
another Arlene Blum is a researcher at
the University of California Berkeley
our chemical regulation system makes us
all guinea pigs because chemicals are
assumed safe until proven guilty and
they go out in the world and we are
exposed to them with no health
information Marc Corral is deputy
assistant secretary of the air force for
environmental safety and infrastructure
is it possible that you've replaced this
with something that could still have a
long-term problem down the road I've got
to rely on the Environmental Protection
Agency and on the health agencies to
tell us whether or not that's going to
be a problem in the future
but for now we're gonna treat it as if
it were any other hazardous material so
that we can prevent contamination in the
in the groundwater and in the soil by
cleaning it up immediately why would you
do that if it's deemed to be safe and
what we're saying is these still are
chemicals that are potentially toxic
side effects dan Cruz worries that more
illnesses may lie ahead because of
something as ordinary as a drink of
water if someone had told you this 25
years ago and you had never had any of
this water do you think it'd be healthy
now and not going through these cancers
I think I would would have been
perfectly healthy I don't I don't
believe that I would have gotten any any
of the other cancers at all
the four million dollars being spent
here at Peterson may just be a
downpayment on the problem the federal
government is studying military bases
around the country to find out just how
far just how bad this contamination
might be and how it might affect
millions of people Deanna
reporting reporting there Barry thank
you so much for that